Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today.
Allison Butler, who's a contributor to the
Media and me, a guide to Critical Media Literacy
for Young People, and also the director of
the Media Literacy Certificate Program at
my undergraduate alma mater, the University
of Massachusetts in Amherst.
Allison, it's really great having you on.
I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Thanks so much.
I'm really excited to be here.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, I guess let's just
start with something.
It's a simple question.
The answer may not be so simple, but it's
something I talk about a lot.
Media literacy, I think, should start being
taught at the latest in seventh grade to everybody.
Probably fifth grade is even better.
It's pretty rare, particularly, that public
schools have media literacy programs.
Is it as simple as it's just not a priority
to those creating the curricula, or is there
more to why it's not commonly taught?
Speaker 3: I think there's more commonly taught
and I would raise your fifth, 2/7 grade to
say we need to start in early childhood education.
Our children are exposed to the media within
immediately.
And certainly with social media we can learn
a lot about them before they're born.
Their identities are out there really early
on, I think.
Yes, it is something that is really can be
understood to be difficult to add to the curriculum.
And part of the reason why it's difficult
is we don't have formal training, formal education
for people who want to teach media literacy.
So oftentimes teachers have to kind of figure
it out on their own and goodness knows they
have enough to do so.
To ask them to add more is arduous.
Part of our work.
Part of my work is to say we need teacher
education and media literacy.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's interesting because
I remember that there were these kind of one
off classes in middle and high school that
were interesting.
I remember one called like Transportation,
Power and Energy, which was really interesting.
It didn't really fit anywhere.
And the teacher who taught it was not certainly
an expert in that field and sort of had to
figure it out as as he went.
And so it does seem that part of the problem,
as you're pointing out, is it's not common
that the teacher base is necessarily equipped
to teach media literacy.
Speaker 3: Correct.
I talk with teachers all the time who say
that they're really interested in bringing
in the study of the media to their classrooms,
particularly because they see how glued to
their devices their students are.
But then they're at a loss for how to teach
it formally.
I think also sometimes, like you mentioned,
these kind of one off classes, they can often
be seen as like what you get to do when you're
done with what you're supposed to be.
Speaker 1: Yes, yes, yes, absolutely.
Speaker 3: Which is sure.
That's that's I mean, there's value in that,
right?
There's absolute value in that.
I wouldn't say that that was that that was
that that's a bad idea.
But I do think it's bad if it's the only way
that we're teaching it because our media are
so infused in our lives.
Why would we then think about educating them
as like an add on or as something to do when
you're done the important stuff.
Speaker 1: By the time people get to you.
So at the college level, what do you find
are the most common blindspots in being able
to look at media and think about it critically
in terms of, you know, we often hear really
young kids can't tell the difference between
advertising and content, for example, or people
can't necessarily distinguish between whether
they're watching news or opinion programing
is a lot more common when for older people,
what are the most common blind spots by the
time people are college age and get to you.
Speaker 3: I mean, I'd say there's probably
two really big ones that can then branch out
into so many more.
One, for the most part, by the time they get
to me, they're pretty good at understanding
the content, but they don't know where that
content comes from.
They don't know the power behind the content,
and that's part of a lot of the work that
I do and that my colleagues and I do in in
the media.
NI is say it's not just about what's on the
screen or just what we're hearing, the actual
powers behind the scenes.
We have to talk about ownership, production
and distribution, and I'd say connected to
that.
But the other big area is, again, by the time
students come to my classroom as college students,
freshmen through seniors, they're really invested
in media.
They're involved in a lot of media.
They have multiple social media accounts,
but have no clue where their information is
going.
Social media is a huge tool of surveillance,
massive amounts of data gathering.
Probably safe to say that most, if not all
of us zip through those terms of service,
zip through those privacy documents.
Don't read the the truly, truly fine, fine
print and all the paragraphs of legalese,
we sign off on them.
It's the only way that we have access to these
platforms, and yet we have no idea where our
information is going, what's happening to
it.
The the one clue that we get is often as soon
as we search for something quite quickly after
that, an advertisement for that very thing
will pop up.
We gave away the data that let that happen.
Do you really dangerous?
Speaker 1: Do you find that over the last
ten years, the usage of social media among
18 to 22 year olds has changed in any appreciable
way.
I mean, one of the things I've read is that
on average, people's use of Facebook is going
in the direction of fewer friends and tending
towards people you really know rather than
a larger circle of friends.
Like that's a change in terms of average Facebook
use.
But do you see that the 18 to 22 year olds
are thinking of their social media presences
differently than maybe a decade ago?
Speaker 3: Oh, absolutely.
I mean, I think maybe some of what's going
on with young people in Facebook is that they
I mean, you know, once people my age got onto
Facebook, it became a lot less interesting
for young people.
And, you know, now that grandma is there.
Right?
Right.
Makes it less fun, I guess.
So I understand from my students that they
use something like Facebook almost more for
like school connections or school projects
as a way of connecting with people.
But I think that in terms of their own personal
use of social media, it's a source of anxiety
that it's meant, at least at some points,
for them to be fun and as its name for it
to be social.
But it can be remarkably antisocial.
You're often pretty isolated with it, and
certainly some of those comparisons against
the beautiful airbrushed images are incredibly
difficult.
But they're also entering a world where they're
expected to know how to use this professionally.
And so that anxiety is not just about self,
but it's also about their preparation for
their future and what's sort of what's to
come next.
And I think in some ways, like, like all of
us deal with certain areas of our life is
that young people can kind of become their
own worst enemies.
They will be upset or concerned about once
it's introduced to them about some of these
surveillance technologies.
But one of the biggest things that's happening
these days is that young people use the Find
My app, where they are constantly tracking
where their friends are.
And what I hear from my students is they use
it so that when they don't text a friend back,
their friend knows it's because they're in
a class where they're not supposed to have
their phones on.
So as much as they might get frustrated by
being surveilled, they also are participating
in that.
Speaker 1: Speaking of phones in class, I
last taught as an adjunct at Boston College
in 2017 and it was a once a week class.
So it was just like, Listen, we're here once
a week.
I don't want to see any phones, period.
Just absolutely no phones.
They're on laptops.
I don't know what they're doing on the laptops.
I don't really want to get involved in that.
But it was just like there should never be
a phone that's out.
How much of an active distraction is whether
they're on social media or not, the phones
in the classroom right now?
What's your sense of that?
Speaker 3: Oh, I think there are huge distraction.
It's so hard for us not to look at our phones.
I actually have a policy in my class that
unless there is a documented accommodation,
need no cell phones, no computers and stop
looking at your smartwatches that we're here
to discuss ideas.
There's no tests in my class.
There's no final exam.
This is about engaging with each other and
engaging with with our discussions.
And most of them can't really put their phones
away.
They sort of turn them over on their desk.
Yeah, I will watch them get up and leave the
room for a few moments.
And I'm assuming they're checking their phones,
but they don't want to get caught checking
it in class.
And at the it there's there's stress about
that.
And some of them do get frustrated with me.
But at the end of the semester, the consistent
commentary I get is this is the one class
I actually paid attention to because I couldn't
be distracted.
Speaker 1: That's interesting.
That's interesting to to get kind of back
to the media literacy part.
A couple other things, too, to talk about
when it comes to how to identify a trustworthy
source.
Anybody who's been in this field any length
of time, we know about all of the things that
are often said.
And it they tend to involve research.
They tend to have you know, it's not oh, hey,
here's an article I just found.
I'm very in 30 seconds going to be able to
do all of the things that on paper we often
say, here's how you identify whether a source
is trustworthy.
What's the lowest hanging fruit that any news
consumer can employ to try to suss out whether
an article or a video clip or whatever the
case may be is coming from a source that can
be trusted.
Speaker 3: I think the first thing to do is,
is an author mentioned because if an author
isn't mentioned, who knows how that got put
together?
It could be PR.
Do you know the website?
Right.
Does it and look closely at the website because
websites are easily manipulated.
So you could have like, you know, New York
Times, dash com dot Gmail or, you know, and
then you're like, wait, I saw The New York
Times, but then it's something totally different,
right?
So truly look at the ending of the website,
almost eve of the URL almost before looking
at the beginning.
Does it look like a real Web site?
Can you get back to that article without to
I mean, look at everything is going to have
pop up ads.
But if it's the ones that are just like overtaking
your screen, can you learn more about the
author?
You don't have to like what they say, but
can you actually learn more about this person
and is not?
I would be suspicious about whether or not
that person is either actually a person or,
you know, potentially a bot or so on and so
forth.
Or if it's somebody who is kind of hiding
behind some other sort of idea or some other
sort of message.
So those would be the absolute first things.
I would also say be really cautious about
maybe the next level would be really cautious
about what you click on on social media.
Social media platforms are not news platforms.
We can share news on them.
But they are not news platforms.
So if we you know, we talk to young people
who say like, oh, I get most of my news from
Twitter.
Well, no, you don't.
You get information on Twitter that somebody
might have shared.
Right.
That might be news.
Speaker 1: You're finding links on Twitter.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Speaker 3: You're finding links on Twitter.
Speaker 1: Another thing that seems critical
that I tell people is to make an attempt to
get to the primary source if there actually
is one, because there's so, you know, there
will be situations where not to pick on any
of these particular news outlets, but you'll
see a raw story article with a headline, and
it will quote Newsweek.
It's actually a Newsweek article that they
are summarizing and editorializing.
You go to the Newsweek article and Newsweek
actually says, as reported by The Washington
Post.
And so you drilling down to where did this
actually come from seems like a fundamental
first step in evaluating it, because really
all Ross story might be doing is rewriting
an article.
You can't really ascertain the truth of the
matter.
You can ascertain whether it's honestly rewritten,
but not the the underlying reporting.
And so finding the primary source seems really
important.
A lot of people may not realize the difference
between a rewritten blog style article and
the reporting.
Speaker 3: Yep.
Absolutely.
And that's true.
I mean, I think one thing that you're absolutely
right is who is being sourced and our sources
being named are those the primary sources
is, you know, if something says something
to the effect of like research shows, well,
where is that research?
I should be able I might not be able to distill
the research myself that quickly, but I should
be able to access the research.
I also think that, especially in the previous
presidential administration, the idea of unnamed
sources.
Right.
What does it mean for a source to go unnamed
for some for some stories that is really legitimate.
There are dangerous issues.
Why somebody whose name out there could be
a problem.
But for others, it's a it's a it's a kind
of a circuitous route around citing your sources.
So part of our work in the media, Amy, and
part of our work in critical media literacy
is evidence based research.
We want to provide evidence ourselves, and
we want people to be looking for evidence
themselves.
Speaker 1: There was even confusion during
the Trump era of when we talk about an anonymous
source, are they known to the reporter?
And there were countless instances where people
misunderstood that even the reporter didn't
know who the person was when the reporter
did.
It's just they weren't they weren't naming
them.
And that's a critical difference.
Speaker 3: Absolutely.
Absolutely. 100%.
Speaker 1: We've been speaking with Allison
Butler, contributor to the Media and Media
Guide to Critical Media Literacy for Young
People, also director of the Media Literacy
Certificate Program at UMass.
Allison, really great having you on.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 3: Thanks so much, Dave.
It was great chatting with you.